Eric what's wrong with political correct
doesn't it mean that I just not allowed
anymore to hold racial epithets a bit of
people outside in my white van you know
isn't that your comedy careers over
political correctness well I think as
you and I probably know the devil is
always in the details that if political
correctness means don't call a black
person the n-word you know we're all for
political correctness it's when you
define racism in an expansive way right
so it's it's when you say if you're in
class reading from a 19th century text
where someone used the n-word that you
are essentially the same thing as using
the n-word yourself I mean that that's
kind of ridiculousness of expanding or
when you say if you're against
affirmative action you are as bad as
someone in the Jim Crow so so that's
really I think what we mean by political
correctness is expanding the overreach
is what yeah overreach sort of this this
elasticity and bending of what Orwell
said you know two plus two equals five
and not only will you agree to that but
you will be made to believe it I mean
this essential when the meaning of words
becomes political and not what ordinary
people how they categorize things in a
social scientific way which is based on
you know the scientific method which is
to do with measurement and clusters of
differences and that's how we categorize
the world Athens instead is about no
this is a racism is what I say it is but
but what this then means is the
expansion of concepts like harm and
racism and sexism and so on a means that
more and more more and more people
aren't you know we could talk about
British politics for example if you say
that the this whole issue about the
Windrush which was about essentially
administrative error and not you know
mess ups at the Home Office but which
was not racially motivated but which
subsequently people like Clive Lewis and
I for Hirsch you know none of these
commentators who are very quick to try
and identify that his racism right so
this broad brush approach but what that
does actually is it there's been about
four experiments which show quite
clearly and there's
I actually done one of these studies
myself whereas if you take the same
statement and you call it racist you
will get a blowback in front in public
opinion people react negatively to that
particularly conservative type voters we
know from the public opinion research
for example then you know most white
Trump voters are actually fairly warm
towards African Americans and Hispanics
you know it's it's not that they are
particularly they're not cool towards
those groups they are just not as cool
towards white people as white liberals
are fascinating because this is a reason
we love talking to you and Matt and and
other people because you've actually
done work on this you're not just
talking about it on Twitter you've
actually done the research and what
you're really saying is that if you
expand these concepts of harm done by
words what that creates is pushback from
people who go [ __ ] you I'm not racist
you know any and that then creates the
polarization that we see which then
leads to election results that we see is
that is that way yes yeah so so you get
to things like in the Trump case
hostility to political correctness was
second I mean in the work I've done on
both the primary Republican primary vote
but also that switchers in the general
election then this hostility to
political correctness next to views next
to wanting immigration controlled and
reduced that seemed to be the second
most important factor let's just pause
them yeah that's incredible is massive
that is incredible people care about
restriction of speech right and being
mislabeled as something they're not
almost as much enough so that for that
to be the primary issue in their choice
for the leader of the free world as they
say that is quite an incredible thing
yeah it is an incredible thing and it
has you know and there's been a number
of experiments where I think in one case
they they were talking about taking down
Confederate statues or something in they
said that this this is a bad policy and
then the next time time they said well
this is the this we don't want this
policy because it's racist or maybe the
wall was that was the example and in all
these cases you could see that when they
threw the term racist in there there was
a lot more resistance to to the
statement right so and so so a number of
these experiments have kind of found
that there's this direct reaction
amongst a chunk of voters enough
[Music]